das ist einfach das dümmste dj spiel
aller zeiten
wer braucht sowas hallo mein name ist
programm wir spielen heute ein dj spiel
oder so ich habe da unten 880 leben 25
cds und muss mit diesen vinylplatten das
sind so automaten reinschmeißen und
irgendwann wenn genug platten drin sind
werden die zugeordnet ist
das ist der sinn des spiels sehr wohl
ein hilfe so viele schallplatten träger
ich komme überhaupt nicht hinterher mit
meinen cds verdammt was mache ich jetzt
ein auto das hier richtig weh hilfe
dieses spiel ist so anspruchsvoll oh
nein ich werde bestimmt verlieren 8 uhr
heilige ich habe so viel am mo 9 4
schallplatten träger auf einmal was
mache ich jetzt ob das in echter ganz
viele freunde
es ist alles in ordnung wir sind ein
paar viele gerade am start aber alles
klar geht natürlich alter okay ich habe
jetzt keine chance mehr
nein nein stimmt dass wir es echt
scheiße geht weg von mir
nein ich habe schon wieder keine mehr
geht weg geht weg geh weg geh doch
einfach beck nein lass mich in ruhe
lasst mich in ruhe
ich kann es nicht fassen dass ich
verloren habe
hallo geht's noch mal weiter das war so
la vie
es hat sich gerade beendet was kannst du
eigentlich so weiter geht es mit diesem
song auch jetzt kommt da schon wieder so
ein scheiß schallplatten dinge weiter
geht mit angry vinyl player heißt das
spiel glaube ich und jetzt gehe ich
richtig ja alles klar dass sportdirektor
da kommt schon wieder die nächsten aller
ich weiß gar nicht ob es möglich ist mit
den verfügbaren cds das ganze zu
schaffen aber so wie das spiel ausgeht
hatten jedoch keine großen analytiker
und statisten damit drin ich habe 47 pds
damit bin ich eigentlich ist es ja sorry
damit bin ich eigentlich ganz gut
aufgestellt aber mir kommst du four
immer wenn ich ein töte spawnen direkt
5000 neue das ist total komisch jetzt
will ich diese beiden da beispielsweise
sind direkt schon wieder so tausende
mehr ich bin ins court 12 ich werd ich
glaube wo bin ich irgendwie westhoff
vierzehn oder fünfzehn oder so verrückt
das werde ich diesmal safe toppen alles
okay noch derzeit freunde hier kommt
zwar wieder gerade ganz schön mächtig
viele von diesen schallplatten spielern
an
auch du da kann auch nicht sein was
denken dass hier so viele auf einmal das
problem sind tatsächlich die
stahlplatten und dass man sich die
einfach nicht holen kann weil da diese
ganzen online ach du heilige nein
freunde
nein nein nein nein nein nein ihr lasst
mich in ruhe ihr lasst mich in ruhe ich
bin einer der besten djs der welt ich
kann so viele wie die platten auflegen
hier geht alle weg ich hab es
tatsächlich geschafft auch tat es da
schon wieder neue mann ich entschuldige
mich jetzt schon mal dafür dass ich
dieses spiel hochgeladen haben es macht
einfach überhaupt keinen sinn
ich kann die ganze zeit ihr vinylplatten
rein schleudern und eigentlich stimmen
ich kann die e mails geht doch nicht die
kinder darunter fünf leben
oh mein gott fünf leben freunde fünf
leben fünf leben fünf leben fünf leben
fünf leben das ist jetzt unterliegen so
viele scheiß vinyl platten die ich mir
holen können
wow und es geht tatsächlich einfach
nicht weiter hallo und das spiel ist
wieder abgestürzt was kann
herzlich willkommen zurück beim besten
spiel aller zeiten ich bin ein dj und
muss scheiß was mache ich hier überhaupt
es macht so viel spaß hier argumentes
game was macht so viel spaß hier wenn
ich wenigstens hüpfen könnte oder irgend
so ein vorschlag machen könnt oder sowas
aber es ist einfach nicht möglich ich
kann ja nicht mal springen kann ich mal
schneller laufen
ich kann gar nichts freunde wer hat
diesen scheiß entwickelt hast es einfach
das dümmste dj spiel aller zeiten
wer braucht sowas ich dachte das spiel
hätte noch einen kleinen zusatzeffekt
hatte ich noch ein paar special text
machen könnt oder ich könnte auch selber
ein bisschen auflegen oder würden
wenigstens effekt bekommen und musik
aber nein es ist einfach crêpes es macht
einfach keinen spaß
man hat mich mal ein ansporn irgendwas
zu erreichen weil man danach die keine
bestenliste sich sondern er steht
einfach direkt game auf und das spiel
stürzt ab es ist einfach so ein
schwachsinn man kann theoretisch auf
einfach stehen bleiben und die schweiz
sachen aber das geht nicht man brauche
im noch mehr tipps das stimmt einen
kleinen sinn hat das spiel sogar altar
okay jetzt langsam drehen die wieder ein
bisschen durch hier gerade aber das ist
natürlich kein link für ein klingen ich
hab natürlich so viele dass ich kann mir
einfach auf die alle drauf schmeißen das
macht nichts für mich ich weiß sie drauf
oh mein gott freuen ich habe an die 100
dies gerade was geht denn bei mir ab ich
bin von 49 was jetzt kann ich echt
einfach disc in die menge schmeißen
alter genauso ist es auch immer wenn ich
auflege ich nehme einfach mit einer
ganzen cds und baller die einfach in die
menge bis alle tue ich weiß gar nicht
was ich dort wieder räder kommen durch
her freunde mir scheißegal ich habe so
viele dass ihr könnt mir alle gar nicht
gerne
hey freundes korff 74 aller freunde was
geht denn bei mir ab wie gut bin ich
denn gerade hier einmal die disc raus
und es werden einfach nicht weniger ist
das ist unfassbar krass gerade jetzt
gerade macht sogar so ein bisschen spaß
das ist so wie wenn man bei ich habe
vier herzen
ach du heilige ich habe vier herzen ich
habt ihr herz und jetzt muss ich mich
langsam echt mal hier so ein bisschen
kümmern ich will 100 erreichen